i thought you could talk to me
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
horror movies don't work with a walther
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
stage lewis
down
stay
do nothing
see he listens
of course the second i start drinking
anything if it's food if it's drink he
thinks uh for me sorry guys that's just
he's we've been having to wrangle him
ever since cal rittenhouse has been in
the studio joe lewis has had a problem
because we had nerf guns and we had the
poppers when he was declared not guilty
and it kind of frightened him so he's a
big scary dog but he's just an absolute
pushover doesn't like loud noises
doesn't like loud noises well that's
wonderful when we take you hunting well
he's the best though he's the best he is
a nice dog we have a we have uh someone
who's been coming by the house helping
with the little ones and the first day
she was terrified of joe lewis well yeah
petrified second day she's in his face
she's licking her
playing with her braids
so
anyway if you're afraid of dogs you know
and i could invite you out here which i
won't you know i would say he can help
you get over it's like touching a spider
that is a big scary dog glad to be with
you today uh look there's a lot to get
to we're going to spend quite a bit of
time on joe rogan today
and trevor noah because there's been a
lot of responses from other people in
the media people who you would be
surprised if you hadn't been following
us that comedians are turning on their
own
but there really is an underlying theme
here it is all about eliminating
competition just like us with the vox
apocalypse it wasn't about some guy at
fox it was about nbc universal one of
the biggest companies who didn't like
that their territory was being
encroached upon we're going to talk
about that today and i want to lay out
the case for you because there have been
some developments in gosh i don't know
where this goes
this is a big moment
for the united states you have the
freedom convoy in canada and obviously
they're trying to tar and feather them
and then here in the united states this
is not going to stop with joe rogan
where it is right now just like you
sustained what was never about covet
because then it became the racist thing
and i guarantee you there's more coming
down the pike
so
we've we've got to make a stand here and
uh yeah i think all of us here uh
whether you agree with him or not
whether you're friends with him or not
need to stand with the guy we'll also be
talking about dave chappelle because
he's in the news again he's in the
crosshairs for comedy no he's in the
crosshairs for you know being a human
being ah and having opinions okay oh no
landowner god forbid well you know pat
oswalt will apologize for taking a
picture with him oh yeah that was ballsy
if i see him
because when i think ballsy i think pat
and oswald yes
if i seem upset today it's because i am
so my question before anything else to
you is uh who's funnier
joe rogan or trevor noah joe rogan oh
come on don't ru don't oh i'm sorry i
didn't mean to give it away i was trying
to force shadow i was trying to
steinberg
or b and then you just gallaghered it
you just smash the watermelon they gotta
stay to the finale i'm sorry you're
right you guys should form your own
opinions if you write trevor noah though
don't unsubscribe immediately
it's it's the only time where in the
comment section it's awful half the time
it's just someone like saying you should
kill yourself right yeah and it's
terrible and of course but if someone
writes trevor noah it you know take the
advice of the comment section uh way to
say it
also of course do not of course no no no
never don't just kill your comment yeah
well yeah of course your your virtual
self the met itself metaself comment and
uh by the way since we're speaking about
this and we see that a lot of people
have been getting in trouble some some
people have been getting removed just
for commenting on the issue
if we're not here on youtube monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern uh watch
us on rumble join mug club today is chat
thursday where we will be taking your
chats for an extra 45 minutes today
along with another segment
mug club and rumble just because we're
not on youtube does not mean that we are
gone tune in all right gerald a how are
you i am much better than you apparently
yes but but really how are you yeah well
yeah you're angry but you had some
business too yesterday with the the the
halfway sometimes people don't
understand that these things require uh
require time and work and
wanting to
you mean wanting to take the comments
section advice to heart you see you mean
you're a busy guy i'm a busy man i'm a
busy man some call me tim
and uh
good i'm glad you're doing well and of
course you know him you love him he's on
tour and so am i on tour with him you
can go to the lottery with credit.com
tour we added a theater uh date to the
royal oak
in michigan in detroit april 16th the
second show was added the first one sold
out really quickly boom and we just
added june 18th pikes peak colorado so
get those tickets quickly and what we
try and do is if it sells out we add
another show yeah so uh
lightercutter.com all right you're doing
sorry i should have said how are you
doing dave good ahoy how are you i
didn't even give you a chance to say the
ahoy ahoy
i hear yesterday uh things got a little
out of hand they were fun they actually
were quite a good time you guys let me
know in the comment section i didn't
have time
i was locked up circle was indisposed
till 6.
we were i got a few letters like uh hey
what the hell are you still on youtube
i'm like what happened no we were on our
best behavior i think well you know
that's a relative it really is well
that's true sort of like when trevor
noah says i killed jerry yeah that's
true sure i'm sure you did yeah yeah
great job right okay new contract before
we get to that
we need to watch this speaking of
comedians there's a comedian heather
mcdonald yeah we used to have the same
manager many years ago really yeah oh
well hopefully you're an agent is it you
have the same agent it doesn't matter no
years years ago years ago he's i think
he he doesn't do it anymore right
probably he's got the booster i think
that makes two of them now but you'll
find it right
so heather mcdonald uh was bragging
look look
everyone stop
because i don't want to get banned uh
obviously it's never funny no when
someone
obviously it's never funny when someone
finds themselves uh harmed in any way
right
what's funny is the irony
in that and i don't mean like an alanis
morrison where she doesn't understand
like what a million spoons knife that's
not ironic
i mean actual irony where she was on
stage this comedian bragging about how
like super vaccinated she is
and then uh
well super a lot of people think that
being super vaccinated isn't what it is
but it do
i don't mean to brag i don't care but i
want you to know
double vaxxed
booster
flu shot
and i'm gonna be honest
i have the shingle shot too
and i still get my period what yes
well nothing like perpetuating the
original stereotype traveled
went to mexico twice
did shows meet and greets must be very
proud of yourself never got coveted
clearly jesus loves me the most
seriously oh she's starting to slur her
words so nice so nice
but that's real
yeah yeah this is real
everybody thought it was a bit for a
minute oh my word it's why they had
their gallagher tarps
now it could be completely to be clear
it could be completely unrelated yeah
to all the mrna technology it's coursing
through her veins well i think she took
all of the shots right before she went
on stage did she she took all these
shots i think you should have the
shingles vaccine yeah so do i i just
shouldn't snort
them hope she's okay wow updates is are
there any updates i do i think she's
okay she was in i know she was in the
hospital
like speaking live so she definitely got
she's okay so they they uh brought her
back and said smelling salty
people said that they thought it might
be a publicity stunt and she was like
guys i went to the hospital i wouldn't
have to i wouldn't have done i wouldn't
have canceled two shows and reads for a
publicity stunt well she also hit her
head pretty hard on the stage yeah she
did i think she cracked herself that was
like when
tim kennedy choked stevo on stage and
then just dropped him and he they are
saying though that bob saggett died of
brain bleed yeah really from hitting his
head right did he does he fainted
something yep
okay not to say there's a correlation
between anything but um not at all no no
no no we would never do that correlation
does not equal causation that's right
you know that's very it's
insanity's 101.
the that's very ironic
isn't it ironic
it's like rain no it's not it's like
falling
on your stage
it's a brain please oh
when you're halfway through your set
what is it with comics passing out these
days what is it with female comics going
my period and expecting an applause
break well no hold on she didn't go my
period she goes my period
who are you larry flint
well if that is how heavy her flow is it
may explain the path yeah exactly it's
just an iron deficiency yeah you got a
river like that you are going to fall
over a river runs through it yeah a new
river of dreams that's a new billy joel
album
and she was dreaming because of the
river uh look we wish her the best yes
for real yeah which are absolutely the
best um and i'm sorry that uh that had
to happen so publicly and hilariously uh
by the way if you guys agree
smash that like button if you think it's
i think it's okay to laugh at that look
jerry lewis is famous with french people
for a reason the french have the worst
sense of humor in the world they only
like you know jerry lewis and freaking
paper mache hats and stuff yeah well in
all fairness that was the best joke she
told all night yes
well that happened to me one time so not
that you know that one
what is funny though is one guy was
dying laughing yeah she was like that is
just a good stuff
was her it was her height man he's like
i'm triple backs too
oh no
his clock stops yes
[Laughter]
um no it happened to me i was doing a
show at a college university and you
guys know i have this bad knee they put
the stage together with these like
multi-purpose wooden blocks yeah and
they shift it apart so i was about
35 minutes into my set i think this i
don't know it was it was vanier i
believe
and uh vanier college in montreal and it
shifted apart and so i'm going sideways
my heel slips in but the ball of my foot
isn't i fall over but my shin is
perpendicular and i hear a tear snap
and i just start you know and you know i
work pretty clean start swearing and
screaming and people just roar laughing
like they thought it was lay low for 35
minutes then go as blue as possible yeah
i was like no this this is this this and
this they thought i was joking
and uh i i didn't get the surgery
because it was canada and i couldn't
even get an mri what the horse is it was
in french yes so i think it was robin
harris you know baby's kids
really really funny comedian but he i
had a heart attack on stage i think and
they thought it was oh man him joking
around too it was like when owen hart
hit the uh turnbuckle a lot of people
thought you know okay this is when
when's the stick gonna be up yep because
there were no bruises anything and they
were carrying them out this is just what
happens this is the problem sometimes
with when you're in the performance arts
uh and of course when your material
relies on your vaginal flow but you know
what i'm not here to judge women can be
funny
too
just to be clear if either one of you
guys fall down on stage on the upcoming
tour it is not part of the show well i
can't probably need to rush and actually
help there's going to be some stunt work
on my special oh yes
like tom cruise yeah i do listen i do
all my own stunts you mean like running
yes no i held on to the outside of a
plane yeah they're not gonna and they
have to insure you for 50 million
dollars they're not going to let you do
your own sense but i ran in a rooftop it
wasn't a rooftop it was a green screen
but it looked like a rooftop
yeah i held onto the top of a plane with
a fan blowing on me yes wow that is
impressive well when you consider my
transplants they could have been
three districts over this is crazy you
haven't seen me upset all right i like
men quite a great deal and by that i
mean entirely platonically
john travolta doesn't have the same
seuss
[Laughter]
he gets listen
he gets into the pressure points
speaking of gail you had me at i.t band
um
there are a few physiotherapists like
this genres for me
getting a little esoteric so uh your
straight hands are here yes
speaking of uh hilarious
now i don't know if you know this you
know uh there's been rising crime we've
talked about at new york city what 42
percent since eric adams took office and
it was up many i mean you're talking
about hundreds of percentages hundreds
of percentage points over the last
couple years the poor guy the new eric
adams the new the new mayor it went up
42 under his watch oh no uh and here's
the thing um al sharpton really you know
the reverend
uh is upset about it now he's upset
about the rising crime because it now
affects him uh on a deeply personal
level you cannot have a culture where
people are just at random just robbing
and stealing and is out of control and
is put on the front page of newspapers
encourages
to do it uh in fairness to eric he's
only been mayor of five weeks but in
but even as i'm fed him eric they're
locking up my toothpaste
first off
i don't really know if uh if uh if
what's the denture well he uses
toothpaste that's a start yes that's
good
i didn't care when they were robbing and
mugging they were raping we had a 300
percent increase in rape
but now i cannot get my sensodyne and my
enamel is suffering
we can't have a city with people no
enamel going around
can i get an amen i love that he's like
a tooth can i get a crest complete
because eric adams without my proper
enamel
then i cannot to enjoy my caramel
[Laughter]
did say someone steals 10 steaks from
trader joe's like that's the worst thing
that's happened in new york well the
worst thing is they had to eat them oh
they're shoving asians in front of
trains but it's like this guy stole a
whole bunch of food yeah did that asian
was he delivering my toothpaste
you gotta ask for toothpaste so i have
to ring the bell to get my two faces i
have to ring the bell to get my two face
and my anti razor bump cream
and it still don't work i got bumps maya
adams i got bumps all over and if i have
bumps that means you're doing your job
as a chump amen
i am useless i love that he still
dresses like a pimp yeah
well he is pimping out his constituency
wow
forever it's a shtick so uh by the way
al sharpton yeah me too
more yeah
yeah he was more fun he was more jolly
getting his ass kicked on daytime tv
yeah but i just think just right now fat
al sharpton just covered in gold would
be hilarious
just
where's my toothpaste
without my toothpaste my teeth are now
made of gold oh because of you eric
adams just a diamond grill it's cause of
you it's gonna end because i wanted it
yeah
look i got my name on my girl you hit it
it spins i don't gotta go my lips
sideways now eric adams uh is the mayor
and he did respond here's his response
the people who
say wiz are real black leaders they're
gonna say listen who's eric you know why
does everything he should be made well
negro you run you run
every day in the police department i
kick those crackers ass
wow
i still like no saltine is safe
and by the way i'm not one of those
people who says like oh cracker is the
same as the android no no no but he is a
racist well yeah he's a racist he's the
mayor version of al sharpton those two
desserts well i feel you shouldn't say
it as a mayor yes that's a good idea
or if you aspire to be one as you i
don't know maybe you just shouldn't
refer to all police as crackers yeah
also uh probably not uh physically
assault them yeah kicking the cracker's
ass might be the reason why they're not
doing anything yes exactly dave got in
trouble for doing the assault with
police officers let's see if we can yeah
we can draw the connection here kick
crackers police officers and then no
toothpaste oh i don't know i don't get
it they're stealing from the store
you're blaming the cops yes we're not
stopping them
i i hate this
i used to love this country well i love
this country i hate that city yeah i
hate this here's the thing they're
locking up the toothpaste they have to
lock it up because people are stealing
everything used to just be high ticket
items um and hopefully you know thanks
to washington free beacon for this
hopefully they start locking up al
sharpton's teleprompter but resist we
much
we must they're all jitty about a
shutdown the tortillas in the race then
co-author of hubris
[Music]
rush limbaugh rush limbaugh rush
limbaugh the show rush lombard hosts
supreme court justice sonia satomaya is
mike is mike uh mockery yesterday and
tony and tony
scalia kim kardashian he gave up
candidates both
first
kazakhstan kazakhstan to college
students in beijing he's getting lunch
at triple h
the gop's tax day giveaway to
millionaires why was traffic problems
email sent
mental projection agency and what
sequestration has done
you know what i'm just
i'm just glad he got out toothpaste
[Laughter]
yeah the fact that he didn't say
toothpaste is kind of a miracle he said
two pics but you know what i'll take the
win i want to see him and joe biden have
a reading contest
i admit i could go toe-to-toe yeah
oh my god
paralysis
well anyone who couldn't get beijing and
uh billionaires
oh he's like i think it was
gorgeous weaver and you know why he
should not
and the only reason he was protected
when he was that dumb is because if you
say he's that dumb people will say that
you're a racist no it's not because he's
black it's because he's him yeah it's
yeah potato keops
we make fun of the white guy version of
him in the white house right now come on
exactly
oh that would know that well that guy's
way worse that would be a great game of
categories i'm telling you dad
they're playing charades and it's like
one of them's having a stroke
you're one of those promotional
balloons in the car lot
just playing scrabble everything's
misspelled but they agree
sounds about right
yeah
all right uh speaking of crime by the
way wonderful sponsor walther firearms
they're a sponsor to the program you saw
that commercial at the beginning of the
show um you can go to waltherarms.com to
shop online for gear parts go to a
dealer near you because you can't
purchase them online look
they have the balls to sponsor this show
i've always said there are great
firearms uh there are many great firearm
companies and i'm not here to trash any
other firearm company but it's sort of
like at a certain point and get a
mercedes you can get a bmw right they're
good cars and i know someone's but you
should buy american well okay but in
germany they don't even have a word for
tow truck so my point is okay we get it
but uh
just go try the walther
try search a review for walther ppq
walther pdp see if you can find a bad
one you can't they're one of the best
kept secrets because they don't have uh
they're on the same marketing budget as
all the other guys in these giant
military contracts but they have us
and we recommend that you support
sponsors to the show all right
let's move on from this i do i have a
walther here always and this is what is
that one the one on your that's the pdp
with a red dot it's incredible another
one on your holster oh this is like a
limited edition one ah i will say it's
obscenely expensive you won't share no i
won't share okay but it's unbelievable i
appreciate that it's very play a little
roulette with it i don't think he can do
it with this it's just going to always
be loaded
it's just
it's just called suicide yeah yeah
they call that dave roulette it's
dangerous if you rack the slitter
and then the bullet
emerges
from yeah and you will find yourself
diad and the freedom seed
cometh forth it is a gum
i tried to chew it but my teeth were too
sensitive because i haven't had my
toothpaste
in a long time
locking up my toothpaste
this guy's watched people get murdered
for the last two years and he's angry
about toothpaste hey how about this lock
up felons not toothpaste
oh there we go comment below can we do
that maybe we need a maybe we need
a shirt for that i don't know at
crowdershop.com i have no idea lock up
felons not toothpaste that's absurd
we're literally putting toothpaste and
razors and shampoo in cages
so that people can roam free who should
be in cages i'm just curious who is
stealing toothpaste that's like the
least stealable item in the world why
would you even care maybe the hobos
think this is their shot they're like i
haven't had teeth i'm hoping it grows
back that's
rogaine for your teeth
i don't think it works that way well
they don't know they always lock up the
uh teeth whitening strips ah yeah well
that yes of course you know a bunch of
stuff's like 50 and up yeah it's very
expensive it's funny though right next
to all the stolen toothpaste with
toothbrushes galore right there's your
heat whitening strips right next to the
anal bleaching strips
i think it's dual purpose even the same
color as the rest of my body
it is like a coffee filter
after two pots
i'd like the michael jackson look please
all right
okay yesterday nancy pelosi uh before we
move on to joe rogan we're gonna spend a
lot of time on joe rogan today because
this is a time to make a stand just like
in canada they made a stand with trucks
here we make a stand with joe rogan
spotify and of course you know hopefully
you support yours yours truly because
we've run into this exact same scenario
before so it's near and dear to my heart
but first nancy pelosi made some
interesting
if hippocritical
requests
of republicans here you go to close by
saying that um
you've heard me say again and again that
the republicans seem to be having a
limbo contest with themselves to see how
low they can go
they seem to have not reached rock
bottom with their she always wins limbo
because she can bend backwards and walk
down the stairs
discourse
legitimate
legitimate political discourse
i've also said that republican
party what country needs a strong
republican party
make great contributions to our country
i say this to republicans all the time
take back your party from this cult
yeah is she dressed like john ritter's
foil on three's company i don't know
i have no idea it's a good call
and that's actually the least offensive
of her garb i hate her so much yeah well
and what you mean by that is you hate
her actions it's wrong to hate you're
right no i don't hate her she seems
wonderful yeah yeah yeah she has a soul
for sure yeah there's no doubt that
she's not
she's just not gonna burn in hell hey
maybe she would be nicer if she was fat
like al sharpton oh well with all that
ice cream you'd assumed that she'd have
some meat on her well she throws up
right afterwards well that's true yeah
and daring
[Laughter]
no it's that's why she orders the pea
soup flavor she's like hogginsta
yeah
so yeah no republicans really they
should listen to nancy look we want to
give credit where it's due they um
republicans you know and conservatives
like myself we wouldn't want covet
hysteria black lives matter or worship
to devolve into a cult or anything
we wouldn't want or the thing the same
kind of behavior that led to locking up
toothpaste you know we wouldn't want
that kind of hysteria to lead to a
cult-like scenario with republic because
that's you know right this is the
republican thing right he may then come
up with a vaccine that is from god to us
and we must say thank you god governor
new york
and i wear my vaccinated necklace all
the time to say i'm vaccinated
all of you
yes i know you're vaccinated you're the
smart ones but you know there's people
out there who aren't listening to god
and what god wants
[Music]
the podlings are playing music
and could you just please apologize
for you know for your white privilege
oh my god about racism anti-blackness or
violence
i thought we were doing the waves
[Music]
that's a that's a good thing to say it's
big
it's so it's large in this country
[Music]
there's definitely a fire here
not an insurrection by the way no
[Music]
that's moskoff
you all made of cosby sweaters
thank you george floyd oh lord for
sacrificing your life for justice
okay
yeah we are the cult you're right i
don't know is there anything else
there's anything else to really say
dave anything else no there's nothing
ridiculous about it oh my gosh i forgot
that that's uh the world now yeah well
it's their world oh wait no it's it's
america what's their party no no mostly
peaceful protests mostly peaceful well
it's you know it's clearly
the conservatives
that have we're the problem dismantled
cosby sweater scarf
i just wish we would have mugged the
corpse of desmond why would you go to
like
just somebody snapped you i like you
apologize for your white privilege and
you're like i just have to find the
right words it's it's you
i'm sorry i'm looking
it starts with it yeah it's it's not
that hard and then you keep walking
and then then if it goes viral guess
what you're wearing a mask
it's pronounced
i just want to take this time and
actually say thank you jfk for your
sacrifice for all of us i mean george
floyd he didn't have well he's coming
back and he didn't do it on purpose
jfk is going to appear once more oh is
he yeah he's coming back my irish
scottish italian like
all my relatives got here in like the
40s
yeah sorry not a lot of privilege yeah
yeah primo carnera who was brought over
as a carnival barker and didn't know how
to box and they just put him in the ring
until he was basically bludgeoned into
brain trauma as he worked off his debt
to the mob i'm sure he really has a lot
of privilege to check yeah it's just
it's enough i'm just done no we're dead
well here's a positive development on
cnn right now seven and a half percent
inflation it was actually higher than we
thought so this is wow good good for the
democrats are just winning on all fronts
wow good for them yeah what was that
weren't they anticipating like six i
think it was supposed to be like right
at seven oh okay so you know i gave them
far too much credit it sucks a little
bit worse than we thought well that's
that's a decade of inflation that's a
decade of inflation
yeah
it's at a 40-year high stephen yeah your
cash is never going to be worth more
than yes yesterday
unless you elect a republican that is
right it's just
wait your cash is worth less now to give
you an idea if you have a 10 return on
your portfolio once upon a time you know
back in america you double your money
every 10 years right that would be if
you had about a 10 yield you would about
double your money every 10 years right
now you'd barely be keeping up with
inflation
you know that five percent raise you got
it's a two percent loss yes it's a two
percent loss technically
and i still can't get my toothpaste no
it costs 10. that's the real crime in
all of this when i go down to my wool
greens
or duane reedy
all right
my when i stop at cbs cbs
[Laughter]
because i got my discount card and they
give me that long receipt with two
dollars off my
pantene
prove
maybe i'll just start shopping at
bamazon
[Laughter]
all right so uh let's get to the rogan
thing because there have been some
developments and this goes far beyond
people throw around the term cancel
culture that's often an umbrella term
used for lazy people uh or they just
want to say look cancel culture
i i told you guys about how i wrote this
book a long time it ended up being
changed my mind there was no term social
justice warrior there was no term
canceled culture
it was called american idiots because at
this point green day was really big and
it was turned down by every single major
publisher saying that it wasn't enough
of a doomsday book because it was
designed to actually change people's
minds um so the term canceled culture is
often used by people now to just say oh
it's cancelled culture so they can kind
of get in on the action there's more to
that here with joe rogan and and i do
think it's important to understand
not just the bad actors at play it's not
bad actors these are major companies
and of course uh the current
administration this is a scary time
and you see what they're doing now with
the freedom convoy in canada they're
trying to say oh it's from the top down
it's from the big big it's big trucking
at it again
right yeah yeah how
didn't you guys do a commercial for
pfizer no no it's big trucking company
big owner operator trucking it's big mac
trucks
um
all right so we covered this last week
jen saki before this kind of happened
where she was calling right on uh
spotify she was calling for more
censorship and when i say this when
people say oh if the government's not
ban you it's not censorship no if the
government is setting guidelines to try
and
curtail your views your livelihood look
let me ask you this if you work right
now whatever you do
uh you watching listening if you're
listening on audio
and by the way i recommend that you
watch because you missed some hilarious
video of al sharpton
uh let's say you're working i don't know
in a manufacturing line okay
and you have a job that you do the same
way every single day and then the
government tells your company hey you
better make that guy actually do it this
way
otherwise
we're going to start looking into your
your company and now you have to do this
job in a way that requires twice the
amount of time
or is much more dangerous for you
that affects you right is it can we say
at that point oh the government's not
doing it to you well no yeah actually
they are when they're when they're
leveraging companies and where they're
making calls out there to try and change
change the playing field
that has existed for a long time and by
the way when i say playing field i mean
a playing field that was set by things
like the first amendment doesn't just
apply to the printing press yeah trying
to change the playing field so that
people can't make a living that
absolutely does fall under the umbrella
of censorship because private companies
cannot operate as private companies when
you have members of this administration
and international governing bodies
telling them what they need to do or
else so we covered it back then and then
i want to get into some updates uh but
here you go is the gensake thing when
people talk about dog whistles this
isn't a dog whistle jensaki watch her
answer she says and i want everyone on
these big tech platforms basically
saying hey look you better start doing
our bidding for us and more importantly
when you see the incestuous relationship
listen to how this question is framed so
our hope is that all major tech
platforms and all major news sources for
that matter be responsible and be
vigilant to ensure the american people
have access to accurate information on
something as significant as covid19 that
certainly includes spotify so this
disclaimer
but we want every platform to continue
doing more to call out misinform and
miss and disinformation while also
uplifting accurate information we want
all of the tech platforms and media to
be vigilant if you see something say
something
and i'm going to get to trevor noah in a
little bit because he commented back
then and he was saying you know now this
is people use it as an excuse to say
that we were right all along when they
were wrong on vaccines and now it's just
that they happened to be right but
before they were wrong
hold on a second i would understand that
if it's just like someone making a
prediction like a jesse ventura right
that's just very broad but when we say
for example no weight masks the way
they're being used don't work and then
go okay it doesn't work when we were
saying for example no you can still get
coveted you can still transmit it and
they were saying nope that's actually
going to be banned uh that doesn't mean
that we were just shooting in the dark
we were very specific when doctors were
saying the two or four percent mortality
rate
uh is not accurate based on what we're
seeing with our patients thousands of
patients right we have a good sample
size and they were banned from facebook
youtube no this is not just shooting in
the dark the point is the government has
been wrong about nearly everything every
step of the way just like they were with
aids we've talked about this remember
they said one in five heterosexual
couples would be uh would be touched by
aids that was a lie or you can say it
was a mistake anthony fauci said that a
child could catch aids from his parents
if they're in the same house from the
same cereal box effectively i don't know
if he said cereal box but he said living
in the same house that it could be
airborne he was either you're a liar or
you're really really shitty at your job
so the point is this when the government
says we need to determine what is
misinformation and they've been
verifiably wrong
that's a scary spot
when if all of big tech answered
jen saki's call right her little
censorship signal in the sky guess what
we're gone right and it's not the
purview of the government to be
determining what is and isn't allowed to
be said by the people they have a
guiding doctrine and it's free speech
period get out of it now there are some
other updates you know neil young you
know neil young said he was going to
pull his music yeah but now neil young
and people it was never about the
coveted misinformation because you guys
have now seen the n-word attack and i
said this with a coven misinformation
it's not what it's about don't apologize
don't back up because guess what p these
people have no intention of forgiving
you you do not apologize to someone who
is effectively an abuser they're just
looking to use it against you they want
you to be wrong exactly and when you
admit you're wrong that's what the
apology is and you know what's coming
down the pike for joe rogan there's good
now it's go they're probably going to
find something lgbtq something that he
said that's insensitive so even though
he's really a classical liberal so it
was never about that
now neil young this is a good example
where people say well companies can do
whatever they want okay well neil young
who by the way some of his catalog is
owned by blackrock one of the most
powerful groups in the world yeah we've
covered that uh now he's not just saying
i'll pull my music
he's encouraging employees he's
encouraged employees at spotify to walk
out
so when people say we don't really care
about your music that much he's like
well you know what now i'm going to try
and start a mutiny so again it's never
enough they want to remove all voices
they don't agree with and then after
covert misinformation what happened oh
no no no sorry did we mean that uh covid
was the worst thing with joe rogan no no
it's that he's racist
and that's the new accusation
look
if this is have you ever been in an
argument with a spouse
and you're arguing about something
legitimate maybe you're arguing about
something legitimate it could be
something as far as division of labor in
the household it could be about
something as far as i don't know you
know getting home at a certain time so
you can spend time with each other or
why don't we have any money and you're
like because i wanted to please neil
young so i quit my job right yes
effectively right
um i'm sugar addict i blew young for a
box of souffret
meal who and i paid him
so if you're in that relationship right
you ever been in that relationship and
then when you're starting to make some
headway
all of a sudden it switches it's like
hold on a second i thought it was that i
wasn't getting home
early enough and then it's like well no
actually it's about the fact that uh
that um you know your uh your your uh uh
that your mom is a like what what
how do we even get to that this is what
happens when they're not actually trying
to solve a problem everyone knows us
bill burr has a bit about this where
people go rogue this is what happens in
arguments when someone knows they're not
winning an argument they just bring
something else out they bring something
else out and so if this was truly about
covid misinformation the fact that joe
rogan used the n-word in a non-racist
context could not be less relevant the
covet attack didn't work effectively
enough and if the racist attack doesn't
work effectively enough there will be
another attack by the way little known
fact about this the n-word controversy
it came from patriot uh takes that's an
organization partnered with a super pac
midas touch
and uh they're the ones who uh of course
uh drew all the attention to this this
is a democrat organization oh just to be
clear i'm the far left organization so
shocked
and when it's odd or that they seem to
disguise themselves as if they're a
right-wing organization right they're a
low-going flag sometimes they do it kind
of like the lincoln project but that's
really more so just a front for
pedophilia crazy
strokes it's the lincoln log project yes
the lincoln super project don't even get
me started on the tinker toys back oh
boy
something else i'm more of a connex guy
so um
here's the thing so are they
rogan can't be canceled uh when people
use that term because he's already been
offered alternatives so a company for
example rumble where this show streams
and by the way just so you know there is
nothing that would make me happier than
to never have to broadcast on youtube
again and all of you to migrate over to
rumble everything that's here on youtube
is on rumble you guys can go to rumble
right now it's just that a lot of people
complain that there's not an alternative
you guys need to migrate there once all
of you migrate there bye bye youtube
just so you guys understand that but we
need you guys to move over
we need to reach people yeah right we
reach billions we've reached billions of
people and billions of people who were
unreached here on youtube but at a
certain point if you get to the point
we're not there yet where you're not
allowed to actually discuss the truth
for example gerald getting us banned by
quoting the cbc
and then the misinformation of it being
dave right
it was a convenient scapegoat well
rumble offered rogue in 100 million to
join their platform and uh he rejected
it because a spotify ceo said to his
employees in a memo that cancelling
voices
is a slippery slope um here's the thing
okay it has nothing to do with
misinformation it has nothing to do with
joe rogan being a racist this has
everything to do with big
multi-billion dollar media conglomerates
trying to eliminate competition yeah
we made it very clear when we went
through the vox apocalypse
that is what is happening right now so
let's go to trevor noah who works for
viacom i don't know what they're worth a
billion i have no idea
still there yeah with trevor noah yeah
oh he is a national treasure he is
terrible at his international treasure
dual citizen treasurer terrible good 50
55 billion 55 billion well you know
billion i rounded down by all of it yeah
wow you're only off by 55 billion yeah
well you know gosh
i didn't want to i didn't want to be
hyperbolic
i did not want to be hyperbolic
how much money do you need because that
would be the epitome of miss anfield
martian
[Laughter]
so
joe uh i bet he wears an earpiece now
where they tell him what to say right
yeah
correct it
mcqueery remember mcqueary mech
kerry i am i'm not queer macdonald queer
mcdonald queer fish for late
where's my two face so uh
joe listen joe they were never going to
forgive you okay uh they were never
going to forget i said he might be
watching um just look at how fellow
comedian and dave we can talk about this
it's always wonderful when comedians
doggy pile yeah yeah and i remember
sounding this alarm back in 2006 2007
when i was a teenager and having been
banned from cultural affairs in canada
saying they're coming for you in
comedians saying no that won't happen
with comedy
it's already happening with comedy and
then what happened is people thought
okay with comedy clubs we can sort of uh
you know circumvent that and do it
online and now you can't even do that so
here's trevor noah a fellow comedian
um
talking about this issue and i encourage
you to go watch the whole video because
everything he says is wrong as well as
unfunny what i found particularly
illuminating is is when he says
i wasn't being racist
i was just being entertaining
no joe i think you were using racism to
be entertaining
you understand what i'm saying i'm not
saying you were trying to offend black
people by the way but you knew that
offending black people would get a laugh
out of those white friends that you were
with i would do that if you didn't no it
would offend black people his joke when
he said it
we walk into planet of the apes
we walked into africa dude we we we
walked in the door and there was no
white people there was no white people
we planted them didn't take place in
africa that was a racist thing
yeah exactly it is a racist thing for
you to say you're saying it's racist but
then in the video you're gonna be like
joe rogan said a racist thing so he
acknowledged it immediately
literally when he said it he said it and
then he's like first time i
and now he's like i never never say
racist people do a thing that's racist
and then they go like no it's not race
can i can i be honest with you honestly
i'm not a scholar i'm not like the the
whatever this is my opinion they will be
stunned to find out you're not amongst
them just truly petrified of having the
label racist branded on them for life
that's what people are really afraid of
yes that's actually that's one accurate
thing they are afraid of that but you
know who's only you know who's afraid of
that
people who aren't racist people are
racist you go you're racist like yeah
the problem is though you've branded
everyone as that right so what
difference does it make now and if you
look at that when i didn't see the plan
into the apes clip i just even
made a joke about it the other day but
when you hear the plan of the apes thing
you go i know exactly what the joke was
yes i know by the way it's it's it's a
and again it's a stupid joke it's a joke
that doesn't even be made and he
acknowledges it immediately he
acknowledges it immediately because of a
geographical error here's the thing he
went to go see that you look at the
timeline the tim burton planet of the
apes okay if you watch that it wasn't
taking place in manhattan it was taking
place in a jungle it was taking place in
an area that obviously seemed exotic
that's what he was talking about okay
just to be closer it didn't take place
in africa look he's not being literal
and right away so okay i didn't mean it
the way that it came out this is what's
gonna happen when you're on air for a
very very long amount of time but joe
rogan should not be in the business of
apologizing and now everyone else is
agreeing with this
to people who will not accept your
apology here's the thing trevor noah was
deliberately misrepresenting yeah
and there are several videos by the way
and they're the only videos that get
significant play on trevor noah's
channel recently uh deliberately
misrepresenting joe rogan's apology i
think we have a clip
i was just trying to be entertaining i
certainly wasn't trying to be racist and
i certainly
would never want to offend someone
for entertainment with something as
stupid as racism
okay uh so right away trevor noah is
misrepresenting it but here's something
that joe rogan said in his apology that
i entirely disagree with and i think
it's why unfortunately and let me be
clear about this this is not
to come down on joe rogan at all this is
to hopefully let joe someone like joe
rogan and everyone else out there we've
been through this and we're still
standing how you handle it
they smelled blood in the water because
joe rogan because you were being sincere
because you're a decent person they try
to use your decency against you yeah but
joe rogan said something
that this is where i think he made the
mistake in his apology but whenever
you're in a situation where you have to
say
i'm not racist
you up okay now first pardon my
language you have kids they should leave
because i have to quote them here and we
can't believe this necessarily in real
time completely disagree with that if
ever you have to say that you're not
racist you up no that's wrong
they want you to feel that way if ever
you are in a position where you have to
defend yourself by saying i'm not racist
someone else is trying to you up
yeah doesn't mean you screwed up because
guess who would never say i'm not racist
a racist and what they try and do is say
i'm not racist that's exactly what a
racist would want us to think no i think
a racist would want you to think that uh
i don't know there's a superior race
dumb ass they tend to yell it they tend
to have a uniform on and they tend to be
surrounded by other people with said
uniforms yeah they're not hiding it
right you acknowledge the racism that
you may if you acknowledge the racism
that gives you the racist branding that
trevor nova is talking about that goes
right under the person that's not racist
exactly that's exactly what they want to
do which is so confusing that i just
said that but that's how the world is
now honestly my eyes glazed over like i
was nancy pelosi but it was true it's
accurate yeah no you're absolutely right
racists wouldn't care exactly you think
robert byrd when he was when he was
recruiting for the clan you think you
think if you think he was marching down
the street with burning crosses hey
you're racist what no oh i'm gonna give
him a piece of my mind not me no
i'm walking next somebody hold my hood
yeah i'm racist walking here
oh it looks like uh we might have had a
little comment from mr noah about this
in fact just recently just recently this
is like this is happening live if you're
watching right now he said well he
commented to us on twitter why didn't
you invite him on to talk about it well
we had your video well i'll have you on
the talk i'll have trevor no one to talk
about have our people reach out to your
people yeah yeah absolutely is this a
public tweet is this a message i don't
know i'll have to find out i think it's
a message all right well mr noah you're
more than welcome to of course and you
know we can exchange contact information
and um you know hopefully you can uh you
know i'm desperate for you to write for
my next special
but i wouldn't want to do your material
because i would be racist no no no no no
look let me be really clear if we have
trevor noah on and i know i wouldn't
make it through the bookers of course
there at comedy central no um
of course it will be respectful and
cordial and i respect anyone who you
know reaches a degree of excellence in
anything um even if it's you know
through the assistance of a 55 billion
dollar company now
but look it's going to be honest you
have to answer these questions no it's
ever going to be enough based on what
you said in your video nothing is ever
going to be enough no let's you're going
to find another thing to go after and
another thing and another thing and
you're going to miss characters no but
can we have amman is that for real yeah
absolutely because that's this is this
this is the kind of stuff that needs to
happen if we ever want to find any
common ground and save this country oh i
don't intend to find common ground with
someone who says he's racist someone
says joe rogan is racist oh no i'm not
saying that you're gonna find common
ground but if but can somebody who's
actually owned by a giant company come
on this show yeah and actually talk to
you hey you know what trevor noah also
put in a word to your guys over there at
viacom to stop false copyrighting our
content that would be great that would
be great because you know people who
have to go out and independently create
shows where we can say whatever we want
and then of course we're vilified for it
we operate a little bit
on a different playing field than you
guys you know you have the support of
big tech and of course this
administration telling big tech what
should be permissible and what should be
impermissible but uh we don't so i would
hope that you go to bat for the little
guy not pull up the ladder behind you i
would gladly have you on the show and if
you've watched any conversation that
i've had with adversarial voices on this
show will be uh 100 percent respectful
and listen to what you have to say uh
even if i don't necessarily respect uh
what you have to say now i think this is
progress
to some degree
i do too and when i use the term
progress i mean
uh it's going to make liberals mad so
because they use the term progress
meaning that got a problem yeah that
sounds good to me right the slow
degradation of the moral fiber of our
country oh that doesn't sound good now
if you guys remember this roseanne barr
she was canceled for making a similar
planet now she made a planet of the apes
comparison but i need to give you
context it wasn't about black people and
planet of the apes she said this is why
she was fired that valerie jarrett
looked like the one lady from planet of
the apes now completely disregarding
race just to be clear i think brock
lesnar looks like an albino gorilla from
the movie congo with the laser gun he
does he does so completely disregarding
race have you looked at ron perlman yes
that man is an orangutan that man isn't
right like there if he yeah there's only
one man on this planet who looks like an
ape it's wrong it's wrong we found the
missing link yeah i mean that is just
well i don't know i have he's i think
it's a strelapivkus i don't know i think
he's a silverback right
snow gorilla he's barely walking upright
they have to put him in a scoliosis back
when he's having i'm pretty sure they
just put peanut butter on his gums and
someone else does his voice
yeah when he did beauty and the beast
they had to prosthetic him uh handsomer
a beauty name it was down between him
and clint howard and it was just that uh
you know ron perlman had to hide sorry
by the way clint we love you i like ron
poman you're incredibly talented now um
the comparison was made between valerie
jarrett roseanne barr made this
comparison and that one lady on plenty
of specific character completely
disregarding race come on come on this
was a comparison that she made
this was a comparison that she made it
looks pretty close and here's the thing
roseanne barr was very clear that she
didn't even know like most of you that
valerie jarrett was allegedly black
i thought the was white
[Laughter]
she seems a little upset
well it is but you don't have to take my
word it was far less offensive to take
her show away say that
that she had an opioid overdose and then
just changed the name to the connors
yeah and you got to respect the cast for
not standing by her and all staying on
the show exactly good people no and i
think the show was going gangbusters
into that right they all said we're
tuning in for the lesbian middle sister
i've it's still on just because i think
abc has to keep it yeah you know certain
things die and kind of live on after
their death hey by the way roseanne
wasn't the only one who made the planet
of the apes comparison just while we're
talking about this double standard um no
who else did
deray you know deray the black lives
matter activist ray remember he
complained that the planet of the apes
used his image because there was an
eighth and a blue vest now i want to be
clear about this we talked about this
when it happened yeah
i went to
i heard deray is it deray mckesson drama
you know uh i think deray is good is
good enough yeah
i had read that deray said hey planet of
the apes you know he was threatening to
sue i believe at one point they stole my
image using my my patented like my blue
vest what are you a cartoon character
you were the same thing every day but
i would have never
ever
drawn the comparison
until i go into a movie and i see the
ape with that blue background
and i'm just sitting there like oh my
god the ray's self racist
i didn't even know
i didn't even notice the vest hey it's
derek that would have never been
watching this and going i too own a blue
vest yes yeah well it's not like the
last blue vessel was he a self-loathing
black man at that point like if it was
it was a spider monkey and a blue vest
would have said that
it's like me watching a keebler
commercial and being like you son of a
you do you live in a tree house well i
did get a great bit of money from them
by the way you might want to switch to
an electric stove by the way guys fresh
cookies yeah
yeah that's true i have killed many
family members with my wooden bernie in
a tree higher speed he's actually uh
responsible for more burst species going
extinct than wind farms that's true
actually yep but he's happy doing it the
red-breasted swallow though is my dear
friend oh lord is that the african
european twelve you know what doesn't
matter it doesn't matter they both
swallow yes uh
what's hilarious too is not even
hilarious look this is the double
standard it shows you again the decency
they want to use your decency against
you joe rogan defended trevor noah in
2015 when trevor noah was accused of
racism this is what rogan wrote he wrote
too much for 140 characters but nothing
he said was out of line and he's a funny
dude f the haters noah that's what joe
rogan said well this is this is
black people can't be racist though
stephen right so that that's i mean i
don't think trevor i don't know that
trevor noah is i don't think he's racist
i think he's bought into a lot of
racially charged narratives i think that
there's a racism that is a constant
through line on the left that everything
either needs to be seen through the lens
of race or telling people that they
cannot
they they've they've tried to gaslight
you where it's like oh they want to tell
you to just pull yourself up by your
bootstraps yes
yes that's exactly it yeah that is
exactly correct and i know that you're
going to counter and say they're just
saying that because they're delusional
because they're white they don't realize
that you can't do it when you're black
well you know what tell that to some kid
with flipper grandkids from the hills of
west virginia okay everyone has their
thing
and yes some people get some tough
breaks and yes we've had tough breaks in
this country
as it relates to race
the
the guy he's from africa and he's on
hosting the daily show
what's a fair point you can do it
yeah
you know i think even if you're not
great no right i mean you can
do you get you give yourself a chance i
honestly don't think i think comedy
central was cruel i think no i think
comedy central was cruel because jon
stewart is a tough act to follow and
they said go
that is true
i wish people in positions like trevor
noah's or anybody who's in the media who
has a voice in the black community
instead of perpetuating these things
lead in a different direction
don't have the victim card be the on
like honestly the only thing that you're
talking about i don't know how much of a
voice trevor noah has well i know it's
unity but
i don't know either i don't know listen
listen i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
compare to say like dave chappelle who's
who does who's racist who does
transphobic is losing the white
community uh well i'm sorry the lib
here's the here's the problem with
comedy i'll tell you right now is the
comics that are actually doing it making
a living don't give a they're they
completely support rogan they support
dave chappelle yeah they believe what
they're saying because they're making a
living at comedy right the problem is
the 10 000 open micros that think
they're comedians who became social or
became social justice warriors it's
these people that can't make a living
the reason why comedy clubs were a place
that were a bastion of free speech where
you thought you were uncancelable was
because people shared in the camaraderie
that you were able to say anything well
i'll never perform at a comedy club
again i'll only ever perform at a comedy
club if they have a written policy that
if you film or if you are offended you
are not welcome here this is a free
speech friendly zone and there aren't
comedy clubs out there that do that so
that's why you when i do these theaters
well you guys well also the enough room
yeah but i don't care if my joke offends
you you're allowed to be offended i mean
that's fine that's your choice it's not
your emotional reaction to my joke is
one thing it doesn't give you the right
in the middle of a club to stand up and
be like you son of a every word
you said well you did go a little far by
doing 12 minutes in the titanium rib
cage i think that was targeted i
think my fall on my face vaccination bit
was stolen
but to be fair you fell forward yes well
fell backwards this put a twist on it i
saw it on like people had put up
pictures of rogan and i only did it
because i'm like okay well i guess we're
gonna stand in camaraderie whatever then
it's like loot all these people trying
to latch onto that it's like no it's
just comics real comics like i've opened
for chappelle i've met joe like i i
believe in what the talent is i believe
that chappelle is one of the greatest
comics to ever live i stand by that
statement of course so i i believe these
people should be allowed to be out there
and say what they want to say the idea
that dave chappelle is getting booed off
stage somewhere disgusts me the idea
that dave chappelle who was embraced by
the black community and by the white
community which is the beauty of comedy
by the way yeah but because he's
rejected by not even the lgb community
but the tqaip community to the point
that white patent oswald has to delete a
picture with his friend and apologize
that's how far we've gone that's why you
don't apologize even if you think you're
wrong you don't apologize to people who
are just going to use it as an attack
i'm sorry i don't agree with it i think
that in a consensual loving relationship
of course you apologize because you're
seeking some kind of reconciliation
that's when one party is not look peace
is a two-way street it's like driving
down a freeway right now you may not
want to hit the the oncoming truck if
they want to hit you you're getting hit
period so don't play ball with them it's
also the phoniness of hollywood though
yeah it's like if i want to be your
friend i'm your friend i'm gonna stand
by you and say that's my friend that's
what it is it is what it is right the
fact that you would have to apologize to
take a picture with somebody that you
came up in comedy with is it's
disgraceful yeah and i'm not gonna say
that patton oswalt's untalented because
he's not he's funny
and it's just the fact that you would
put out a picture disgraceful as a man
now yeah now that's disgraceful as a man
it's you and your friend there's no
reason you should apologize for putting
up a photo of it it's just cruel to do
to somebody who's been in your life yeah
to do to what please a mob of whatever
people that can't be pleased it also
shows you how it's not enough because he
did that whole special on george floyd
you know chappelle dave chappelle was
absolutely on board with a lot of the
black lives matter uh you know he went
after candace owens heart and candace
owens
is more forgiving of dave chappelle yeah
than this group think of that for a
second she was immediately forgiving not
even not only forgiving she wasn't
bothered she wasn't bothered yeah well
moments like these reveal people's
character so just watch what people that
you think well of are doing in these
cases well here's what i want to get to
here's the root cause of this issue and
i'm glad that trevor noah as message
because we can talk about it though i
think there are certain third rails that
he won't be allowed to talk about
because when you try and convince people
that you authentically can say whatever
it is that you want to say
and it's different from people like joe
rogan or myself uh it's pretty tough to
have an open conversation i'm trying
read through the lines
noah's attacks
or at least what i would say is
misrepresentations on rogan it has
nothing to do with racist language now
here's another video that he uploaded uh
where he insinuates that
the problem is because and he's not just
saying the problem in the sense of an
objective uh sort of
observer saying oh the problem is now
he's mainstream and so there's you know
people are now going through his stuff
with a fine-tooth comb
watch the context he's saying you
shouldn't be mainstream you should be
niche which is ironic considering the
audience size and the difference but
that's also they want to keep this
facade alive that my god people actually
tune in to watch trevor noah on uh on
comedy central or my god people tune in
to watch brian stelter or my god ryan
williams is an actual journalist they
need to keep that lie alive and so now
you have trevor noah using the what
this is basically the bully approach of
well now that you're at the you know
it's okay to be over there but you can't
come to the the cool kids table
watch because like what happened here
was joe rogan was fringe right so he was
like in his corner of the world doing
his own thing doing does this mean like
i know this is good like a weird concept
but like okay joe rogan was friends he
was in the corner of the world doing his
own thing with his friends by the way
saying whatever they wanted
then the podcast got bigger got bigger
and it's still there
and even like when it was huge it was
still like fringe then spotify came and
they were like yo we want to make you
mainstream if you stayed in his fringe
lane
you find this would have because these
videos have come up and gone and come up
with but the people most people didn't
see it because it wasn't in the
mainstream that's not true you know what
i'm saying
that's the curse of mainstream it
doesn't matter if you're a musician
doesn't matter if you're a person
doesn't matter for your thing it's like
be careful you make your thing in a
corner and then when you come to the
rest of society
be careful about what they think of your
swinging dick is what i'm saying
i hope i hope i've shed some light on
this situation hey that's the funniest
thing by the way with spotify's like by
the way you know what a comedian should
never be
careful
you know spotify bought joe rogan
because he was huge and they were going
to make money off of him well they got
into they didn't even buy joe rogan they
bought the rights right yeah nobody goes
to no but it is not 1920 where they're
like i'm gonna make you a star kid right
right exactly all they knew was see they
tried it with noah yeah
joe rogan had one hell of a corner if he
if he was off in a car somewhere we're
gonna make you a star just stay away
from that apartheid in a farmer business
but we should we sure think that the
americans will like you because you're
ethnic but not so ethnic that you
intimidate white people they let you
date their daughter yes this was all
there this was already as big as it is
now i would argue it may have even been
bigger before it was on spotify right
that's true but trevor noah actually
just said something there that should
shock not shock everybody but it should
shock him he just revealed the play the
play isn't that the content the videos
have come before and they've gone
they've come before and gone no no
you're right when he went to a woke
company that people like governments
want to put pressure on
then it became an issue right not the
content because the content has come and
gone before and by the way i think a big
reason i think a big reason that joe
rogan went to spotify is because he saw
the way the tides were turning on
youtube and he thought you know what
okay if i go here at least i can say
what i want and that's what they said
that was
contractually that was part of the deal
and now that's changed so okay youtube
maybe not okay well then spotify okay we
can't do that how about facebook no how
about twitter no this is what's
happening okay well at least let me let
me create my own app and i'll just oh no
wait you're gonna be banned from the app
store well uh let me get my audiobook on
amazon oh no that's going to be bad
we've seen this happen everywhere you're
talking about a consolidation of power
with really five companies let's call it
six to be generous
and all of them are doing the bidding
of the united states government and
people like trevor noah cheered on if
you stayed in your fringe lane
hey
how about how about no how about you
actually celebrate that a comedian came
up organically how about you celebrate
this is the thing i remember watching
joe rogan
okay i remember watching joe rogan back
when he was on his webcam a long time
ago long time ago i was in montreal and
i was watching it and he was lucky to
get you know you're talking about a few
thousand viewers at this point it was
mainly on his website remember if anyone
forgets about this nick diaz hey train
by day joe rogan by night all night
every day this is something that
happened a long time ago as part of his
intro i've been following him for a long
time remember it was just him in a
webcam and one thing that he would
always say
and i would echo this
it was inspiring to me when i was coming
up he said the beauty of the internet is
that there's no gatekeeper anyone can do
it he
he changed when he was on tom green's
show that was in his basement at one
point he said this is great you're doing
it on your own and this is joe by the
way joe rogan was hosting one of the
most popular shows in the country at
this point he had been on a news radio
he was hosting fear factor and he had a
contract with the ufc
and he decided to go out and take a risk
and he was saying this because i want
other people to do this because he was
tired of dealing with executives also he
did he did work with the ufc for no
money early a lot of people don't know
that either this was a budding this is a
man who takes risks and who actually
puts his money where his mouth is he
just said i'm a fan i'll go and do it
and i think at a certain point he said
well it just cost me too much money to
travel and go out and do he was doing it
as a fan and now of course he's wealthy
working with the ufc as he should be he
started it with a webcam and he talked
about how there are no more gatekeepers
so here's this is the contrast joe rogan
throughout the entirety of his career if
you want to go through and pull some
racist stuff fine
but go look at his early content you
will see
a constant him saying hey we don't know
what's going to happen we're just trying
to make this work because i don't have
to deal with executives telling me what
i can and cannot say on the flip side
the people who want to get rid of him
the neil youngs who work with blackrock
the trevor noah's saying you should stay
fringe really try let me ask you this
driver noah and maybe i'll ask you this
when you're on the show do you want a
world
where comedians
have to live in your world of the
viacoms
let's go through the companies what is
it uh abcdisney
nbc universal uh
viacom
i don't know the viacom turner
there's turner viacom there's about five
or six companies trevonne is that the
world you want
do you feel more free than joe rogan
do you want comedians to look to your
situation and say oh yeah yeah i want to
do that where i have to be at home for
two years because of the policy of covet
and i'm not even free to go in front of
a live audience which he still isn't
right now or do you think that you do
you want younger comedians to at least
look to joe rogan and say oh great i can
do it and i don't have to be beholden to
someone else dangling a check do you
really believe
that the moonveses
that the weinsteins of the world that
the zuckers that the roger ales of the
world i had to deal with that do you
really believe that they have the best
interest at heart of entertainers of
performers of people who should be free
to speak their minds and their opinions
do you believe that's a better world for
people like you and people like joe
rogan because you are a quizzling for
them whether you mean to or not and i
don't say this with a hint of hatred
i say it with tremendous sadness
because this beast is going to swallow
you whole too man
it absolutely will and by the way
ironically when he says this is fringe
well you know what
i don't know if he believes it just like
when brian stelter was bitching that
people were trust that it's a problem
they're trusting joe rogan more than cnn
well stop sucking at your job cnn for
starters
i believe for seltzer it was fridge yes
well i yeah well he wasn't concerned
about them locking up toothpaste no he
was just concerned about them locking up
lard paper they're locking up my beef
tallow
so trevor noah's most popular video 18
million views with the assistance of
viacom joe rogan 51 million views i
don't know if we have the screen grab
that i asked you guys to bring up tommy
lauren yeah yeah with tommy okay yeah if
we have the screen grab of his recent
videos you know he has how many million
nine million subscribers he's lucky to
crack out the only videos that are
immensely popular are the ones that are
addressing joe rogan and we're talking
about short clips produced by viacom
joe rogan i'm so uh sorry lewis joe
lewis i'm sorry joe
i don't know i'm talking about cl short
clips that have the full promotional
authority of uh uh he'll be fine yeah
okay they have the full promotional
authority of a 55 billion dollar company
and it gets less than not to toot my own
horn
than the hour and a half show that we do
every day
yeah not to mention the short clips
and you want to say it's fringe it's gas
lighting it really is it's it's fringe
and then a lot of people are going and
how many at least 11 million people are
going uh
no it's not but there's three hundred
thousand people at cnn going yeah those
eleven million they're fringe
insane
they want to change they want to
maintain a death grip on the political
landscape the media landscape
and they want to make you think that
they are not and they want to make you
think that you are in some fringe
minority and you are not just like dave
chappelle is not we have a segment here
on dave chappelle but you know what i
guess we'll probably have to do it on
mug club listen
please and if you want to have trevor
noah on the show uh you think it would
be a good conversation do me a favor
smash that like button do it i think it
really would be a good conversation i
would i would absolutely like to have
i'd like to have him in person though
because with skype and everything it's
all that's stupid yeah like a real
conversation like something needs to yes
stuff just needs to happen and uh leave
a comment on it we're gonna talk about
dave chappelle and zoning laws because
uh apparently he's racist now oh no
something like that i don't know youtube
piss off
can you hear me
well we're behind the paywall now he's
he's certainly not a subscriber oh i
don't know
well i mean
if he's watching and it's like he wants
to dm then yeah come on the show was it
was it a dm there together or i'll go on
his show
i'd be like what's up
how are you doing babe you're going so
he can come on our show you know as long
as it works with a schedule i made it
about
me i volunteer as tribute yes i'll come
on and be like yeah
fringe i think you made a really good
point like i like how you wear a sweater
and a sport coat at the same time how do
you do that aren't you warm anything to
avoid a collar well no it will swallow
him up that that complex that he's
actually he's perpetuating it as well
right he's gonna touch his hair shut up
dave he's probably i'm kidding i love
you and he's perpetuating something that
will ultimately end up destroying him
and anybody else who comes after him
he's making it worse for the next
generation of comics he's also getting
rid of one of his guardians because joe
rogan was the one who defended him